there are only so many major political
events globally each year and we have
one that is transpiring right now the
british prime minister boris johnson of
the conservative party colloquially
known as the tories has announced that
he's going to resign his party has lost
confidence in him it has been
humiliation after humiliation and up
until the last moment boris johnson was
saying resign why no why would i resign
and he is now resigned or he will resign
once a replacement is found um a very uh
good report about this from the
associated press britain's boris johnson
resigning as prime minister amid scandal
this is another trumpist type
whose political run is at least for now
ending in completely humiliating defeat
of course you know pending what happens
with trump in 2024 there may be more
written in the trump story but this is
another
trump in type
who is getting humiliated out of office
prime minister boris johnson announced
his resignation thursday
amid a mass revolt by top members of his
government marking an end to three
tumultuous years in power in which he
brazenly bent and sometimes broke the
rules of british politics months of
defiance ended almost with a shrug as
johnson stood in 10 downing street and
conceded that his party wanted him gone
let's look at a bit of that announcement
and yeah i i the the ap
very uh accurately saying it was months
of defiance and this sort of faux
principled indignant defiance resign
i am here to do a job for the people of
the
yeah i guess i'm gone
i don't know good afternoon
it thank you thank you
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister right i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
so i want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time thank you
for that incredible mandate yeah i mean
the message should be to those who voted
for the tories for the first time
you're probably never going to do it
again the biggest conservative majority
since 1987
the biggest share of the vote since
1979.
yeah so uh there it is boris johnson
resigning in shame a little bit more
from the associated press article
the brash 58 year old who took britain
out of the eu and steered it through
covet and the war in ukraine was brought
down by one scandal too many
this one involving his appointment of a
politician who had been accused of
sexual misconduct now i have to tell you
in reading through this johnson is a
sort of british version of trump in many
ways not just the hair uh the kind of
brash
never apologize type nature and you know
the sort of pseudo-right-wing stuff yeah
but i have to tell you at this point
american politics has fallen so far like
into the toilet for lack of a better
term people are flushing toilets 10
times 15 times american politics are so
in the toilet that if trump had done the
exact same things johnson did i don't
know that it would have been even a
fraction of the big deal that it became
in the uk
uh the messiest of prime ministers did
not leave cleanly the article says
johnson stepped down immediately as
conservative party leader
but said he would remain as prime
minister until the party chooses his
successor the timetable could be
announced next week from what i'm
reading we could be talking about months
during which a it's a sort of lame duck
by by self-designation
situation there he could be there for
months still many in the party wanted
him gone before then his government has
been shredded by scores of resignations
and there's a long long list of those
johnson clung to power for two days
defiantly telling lawmakers wednesday he
had a colossal mandate from voters
massive dumps of votes he had guys and
intended to get on with the business of
government but he was forced to concede
defeat thursday after one of his closest
allies newly appointed treasury chief
nadim zahawi
publicly told him to resign for the good
of the country look at these numbers
about 50 cabinet secretaries ministers
and lower level officials had quit the
government over the past few days often
castigating the prime minister for his
lack of integrity so a very interesting
and big story
the real the most relevant question
arguably
globally about this resignation
is okay so you replace johnson with
someone less cartoonish
but does the uk's
positioning
in geopolitics change on any major issue
does do trade relationships change in
any major way as a result of this no
probably not um does the british
position on the ukrainian uh defense
against the russian invasion change no
probably not um and so it is a very
it's a personally scandal-ridden
individual who's now going to be
replaced but there's really no reason to
think that in any substantive capacity
um the uk's geopolitical positioning is
going to change and you could say well
that's a good thing or that's a bad
thing or stability is good but actually
change would be good because the uk has
become much more right wing than many of
us on the left would like to see
um
we'll have to see where the dominos sort
of fall as far as that goes but this is
primarily
uh a personal scandal
with within the context of the
conservative party who will now choose a
new leader and subsequently there will
be a new prime minister now there could
be follow-on effects uh at the time of
the next election and depending on what
happens within the united states in
terms of the midterms in 2024 you could
certainly see a shifting dynamic in the
relationship between the uk and the us
and in the uk's positioning globally
none of that is happening right now this
is johnson is out he will be replaced
other than again the sort of like
cartoonish nature of johnson i don't
anticipate based on everything i'm
reading right now that there will be any
radical or substantive changes certainly
to our relationship with the uk but not
a good couple of days for boris johnson
and very much like trump defiant until
the final moment
with trump it was well
making every claim about how he was
going to stay in power because he really
won and then just quietly leaving not
even going to the inauguration with
boris johnson
for weeks and weeks
remaining indignant about well what do
you mean resign
two days even when it was clear the
pressure was overwhelming saying why
would i resign and then i'm out and
we'll see what the next step is
folks we have to now pray at the altar
of joe biden
joe biden has now
reduced gas prices 22 days in a row
how did he do it obviously because joe
biden was to blame
for higher gas prices
in every country we must now praise joe
biden for this notable
extended decline to gas prices
i'm not actually being serious but let
me tell you what it is that is going on
and then we will talk about it gas
prices continue to drop
gas prices fell another two cents
yesterday to 477 per gallon
according to the latest aaa data down 24
cents from the highest ever recorded
level of five dollars and one and a half
cents last month
gas prices are on track to continue
falling
though maybe not fast enough for
president joe biden who has criticized
gas stations for keeping prices uh
keeping prices high
so i tweeted
sort of tongue-in-cheek yesterday
gas prices have declined 21 days in a
row
how did joe biden do this
it was completely satirical
and with 50 000 likes on that tweet as
of this morning and maybe more at this
point in time
uh most people understood it
but not everybody and some people
thought i was being serious and actually
responded to me saying david joe biden's
irresponsible actions are responsible
for gas prices having gone up
but he didn't do anything to lower them
oh okay so when a democrat sees higher
gas prices it's their fault
but when a democrat sees declining gas
prices it has nothing to do with that
democrat i've got it now of course you
would probably be asking one of the same
questions i've been asking
how is joe biden responsible
for gas prices being up
in most countries over the last year
and how can we now say he has nothing to
do if that is his major responsibility
which is incredible one man responsible
for higher gas places globally now they
go down and we say it has nothing to do
with him that doesn't really make a lot
of sense when gas prices go down under a
democrat conservatives say nothing it's
only when they go up and remember when
prices were up under donald trump
conservatives said nothing they didn't
complain i wonder why that is so we can
look at um some of the data here gas
buddy is a good website tracking this as
you can see there was this peak just
under 502 per gallon right around uh
what was that mid-june i guess we would
call it
um and now gas prices down
not a crazy amount down about five
percent
now there's a couple of different things
that are going on
one of them is that the price of crude
oil
has started to decline relatively
significantly you might remember that
briefly in march crude oil prices hit
what was this 123 dollars per barrel
crude oil is the source material for
what is eventually refined into gasoline
that we
not me i'm on electric now but that
people
put in their uh put in their cars and
speaking of electric vehicles there's a
reason i bring that up
sustained high gas prices aren't
particularly good
for the oil industry you might think
well the higher the gas prices are the
more money they make
in the short and medium term maybe but
if the longer the the gas prices are
sustained at a high level the more
people will say when it comes time to
replace their vehicle i'm going to get
off gas altogether and go to an electric
vehicle
that's not good for the gas for the
gasoline industry so we had that spike
to about 123 uh per barrel in march and
then we had another spike almost to the
same level 122 dollars per barrel about
a month ago and now as of yesterday oil
prices were all the way down to what
does this look like about 98.99
per barrel that's a pretty significant
decline
in a perfect world you would eventually
see that same proportional decline about
17 18
trickle down to gasoline it almost never
happens i'm reminded of uh we've seen
those who have those of us who have
paid attention to or purchased airline
tickets over the last 15 20 years
remember that every time that um jet
fuel prices and crude oil prices go up
um airplane tickets go up and sometimes
there's fuel surcharges and all these
different things but then when the
prices of jet fuel come down and crude
oil come down those are rarely if ever
removed they're sort of like permanent
and
we often don't see gas prices gas prices
will mirror
the increases in oil prices but they
will not mirror the decreases but
needless to say i don't think joe biden
really has anything to do with this i
didn't think joe biden had anything to
do with gas prices going up and i think
he has essentially nothing to do with
gas prices going down he released a
little bit of oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve
very modest impact and that that's
really the tool other than you know
going to war with an oil-rich nation or
a gas tax holiday
um
releasing uh supply from the strategic
petroleum reserve is one of the very few
tools presidents have this stuff is
global this stuff is cyclical it tends
to move relatively slowly we're now it's
about three and a half weeks and it's
like a five percent decrease that we've
seen so
my expectation and i don't really make
predictions that i would ever suggest
anyone
make any financial decisions on my
expectation just based on what we've
been seeing we've seen a slow down in
the growth to the inflation rate i
expect to see that continuing to come
down gas prices are going to be a part
of that and my my guess is and it's not
a guess i'm betting on remember this is
my guess
but in terms of financial stuff i'm just
doing the same thing i always do just
every month
maintaining my asset allocation i'm not
making any shorts or investments in any
commodities i think over the next six
months we will see inflation taper off
uh we will see gas prices continue to
come down particularly as we are now we
are now at a time that gas prices are
often really expensive the the summer
driving season as it's often called and
i think six months from now things are
going to look a lot more uh more more
reasonable what we're now getting to and
we talked about this yesterday with pat
on the bonus show
is that first there were recession fears
because of such high prices and
inflation
now as we're seeing that start to taper
a little bit
there are recession fears over a demand
collapse so either way you'll find
people who have recession fears i have
no idea if we're heading into a
recession but at least the gas price
numbers are starting to come down and
i'm ready for all the right wingers who
blamed biden for gas prices being up to
praise him for them being down i'm ready
i'm not expecting it i'm not holding my
breath but i'm ready if they want to be
at least consistent let me know your
thoughts let me know what you're seeing
locally you can find me on twitter at d
pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so now they're blaming antidepressants
and marijuana cannabis for the mass
shootings that the united states is
plagued with that's where the american
right wing
now is so let me show you something
interesting before we dive into these
latest claims here are previous stories
that i that i've done over the years
covering
the different things that the right is
blamed for mass shootings and notice
what's missing from this list so this
this is over the last many years on the
show
fox news blamed masks like coveted masks
abortion
and woke for mass shootings in the
united states
they've previously blamed joe biden for
mass shootings
they've blamed rap music video games and
coveted lockdowns
for
mass shootings right winger brian fisher
and fox news blamed the fact that some
churches ban guns
for mass shootings in churches not long
ago and famously cartoonishly ted cruz
republican senator from texas blamed
doors for mass shootings here's one from
the archives way back in 2011
a wacky arizona sheriff
blamed rhetoric
for a mass shooting okay
notice that guns are completely missing
the guns are what
the shootings are done with a gun
but they never talk about guns they talk
about everything other than guns and now
it's marijuana and it's anti-depressants
laura ingraham on fox news talking about
this we talked about this a little bit a
couple of weeks ago and she's still at
it she did this again this week based on
the latest shooting in highland park
illinois
but instead of selling fear and division
wouldn't it be nice if we all began to
focus on solutions don't people want
solutions i suggest they do
now on the mass shooting in illinois
indications are that robert cremo was a
regular pot user now one look at him and
to the untrained eye he looks like a
complete psychotic you ever seen anyone
looking like him now the the his
appearance
we don't yet know but there are many
medical professionals actually
speculating that his physical appearance
is indicative of of a syndrome uh
let's just leave it there so the point
is if you want to look at the physical
appearance there's definitely lots of
questions raised by the physical
appearance but the marijuana piece seems
sort of like neither here nor there and
what can regular pot use trigger in
young men in particular
psychosis and other violent personality
changes not everyone but a significant
percentage okay so it is not a
significant percentage and we actually
have good studies on this we have actual
peer-reviewed research it is true
that some studies have found
a slightly higher likelihood of violent
behavior among cannabis users but
haven't been able to establish any
causality at this point it hasn't been
established that cannabis makes people
who were not already predisposed to
violence to be any more violent and
lastly there's no evidence i was able to
find that cannabis use makes people more
likely to commit crimes even if some
criminals are high on cannabis at the
time that they commit a crime there's
been no causal relationship that's been
established and maybe most notable i
mean sometimes we just have to say does
this pass the sniff test the prevalence
of cannabis use is way higher in a ton
of countries that have almost no mass
shootings look at pot use in the south
american country of chile
almost no shootings
look at canada
third in the world in terms of
per capita cannabis use
almost no shootings israel
super high cannabis usage almost no
shootings you get the idea
so that's uh
cannabis
now antidepressants this is another one
this is a recycling of something that
others have talked about alex jones used
to talk about ssris ssris are selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors these are
often prescribed for anxiety and or
depression some of these have been
around at least 50 maybe even more like
70 years um very very safe and well
studied class of drugs marjorie taylor
greene radical republican congresswoman
from georgia is now on the ssri
bandwagon she tweeted quote
when are we going to have an honest
conversation about drug abuse
mental illness and ssris
deadly side effects are we really going
to keep pretending
or covering for big pharma
because i'm absolutely done with the
political plays on this bs
there is no evidence that ssris cause
people to be violent now this requires a
little more thinking and thinking is not
a common it's not a prevalent command
it's not an abundant commodity in
general and particularly among the
american right
one of the considerations is
people
predisposed to violence
might be getting prescribed the ssris
that's not evidence that the ssris
caused the violence but it's a potential
reason for why violent people might be
on ssris that's one thing
the second part of it and this is a
really big issue
lots of young people prescribed ssris
aren't actually taking them or taking
them as prescribed
there's a study
and you
are you guys willing to think with me
here because otherwise we're in trouble
there's a study that found a small
association not a causation a study
found an association between people 18
to 24
on ssris and violence and that
association doesn't exist for those 25
plus so you look at people 25 plus on
ssris no association between ssris and
violence you look at 18 to 24 there's a
small association between being on ssris
and violence association not causation
and the study recognizes
the study is based on what people are
prescribed
not based on what people are taking
the 18 to 24 group might be more likely
to not actually take the medication that
they're prescribed
and if they took the medication it might
reduce their propensity for violence
this is the exact same thing that
happened with now i don't remember if it
was with ivermectin or with
hydroxychloroquine there was this brazil
it was ivermectin a brazilian quote
study
supposedly quote found
that people given prophylactic
ivermectin were less likely to get
coveted or to become seriously ill from
covid and then the study was eventually
debunked and shown to be a very poor
study because it wasn't a controlled
study of any kind there was a community
where um ivermectin was just handed out
and there was no actual way to know did
the did anybody actually take the
ivermectin did the people who didn't get
sick were they actually taking the
ivermectin if i were to just go into a
neighborhood and hand out some
medication
and i don't actually know if anybody
took it and even if they say they took
it did they actually take it the way it
was prescribed and then i make some kind
of conclusion from that it would be very
bad science and similarly the one study
that found this small association among
18 to 24 year olds between violence and
ssris we don't know whether actually
they were taken we just know that they
were prescribed so it's more junk
science and notice they will throw
anything they can at the wall
see what sticks
other than saying we've got to deal with
guns
earlier this week i told you that rudy
giuliani and john eastman two former
donald trump lawyers and republican
senator lindsey graham have all been
subpoenaed by a court in the state of
georgia and it's become very common
for
republicans to ignore subpoenas from
congress to appear before the january 6
committee but ignoring a subpoena from a
court is a very different thing well
we've now heard from republican senator
lindsey graham he says he's not going to
cooperate with the georgia trump
election probe now importantly some of
you wrote to me and said how can lindsay
get away with this this isn't he going
to be thrown in jail for a contempt of
court understand lindsay's not saying
he's going to ignore it he's saying he's
going to fight it
he's going to try to fight the subpoena
senator lindsey graham reports reuters
will not comply with a subpoena issued
by a grand jury in georgia investigating
trump's attempts to overturn the results
of the 2020 elections quote senator
graham plans to go to court challenge
the subpoena and expects to prevail said
i guess two of his attorneys they say
graham was well within his rights to
discuss with state officials the
processes and procedures around
administering elections
what they're referring to is that graham
called
and
you know
it was very clear he was trying to
strong-arm georgia into flipping the
results but what they're calling it is a
discussion about procedures
very benign way to refer to it the grand
jury also subpoenaed rudy giuliani and
others the grand jury was selected in
may to look at evidence in a probe
launched after trump was recorded
on a phone call pressuring state
officials to overturn the results
graham's attorney said in the statement
that the senator was being called simply
as a witness in what they call a fishing
expedition any information from an
interview or deposition with senator
graham would immediately be shared with
the january 6 committee they don't like
that
and he is going to try
to fight the subpoena now
if he tries to fight the subpoena and
loses and a court says
you have to respond to the subpoena
and he doesn't he would then be in
contempt of court that is not where we
are right now if the court decides he
must comply and he doesn't it will
become a legal issue for him unlikely i
have to tell you that he will end up
arrested because he's not again he's not
a subject or a target of the
investigation he's merely a witness he
still could be held in contempt he could
face daily fines if he ignores it it's
not likely that he's going to be
imprisoned and if he still
didn't pay the fines that are assigned
to him for ignoring the subpoena then
his assets could be seized but it is
very unlikely that lindsay's actually
going to get himself arrested
that's where we are right now
of course it would be great if everybody
just complied and they could tell us
everything we need to know and it would
be very clear that everybody's innocent
nobody did anything wrong and then we
could just all move on with our lives
but instead they are obstructing and
impeding and trying to get in the way of
these investigations at every turn i
will remind you
my opinion remains
that it is more likely that if there are
going to be big time charges even
against trump which i don't think is
particularly likely but if it's going to
happen
i believe it's far more likely to come
from the georgia investigation than from
the january 6th investigation and i've
given the reasons why already
and uh that's where my mind remains
obviously if they don't get people to
comply with subpoenas it will be much
more difficult to build these cases we
will have more on all of these stories
on the david pakman show instagram which
can be found at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow dozens of you sent me
this clip that we're going to look at um
congresswoman debbie lesko who's a
republican i probably didn't have to
tell you that you could probably figure
it out from what she said she's from
arizona she said on the floor of the
house of representatives that she would
do anything for her own grandchildren
including shooting them
what what does that even mean now did
she just misspeak well if she did
she hasn't clarified it she's responded
to criticism of this bizarre statement
by saying people are attacking her and
all these different
if she misspoke she could just say she's
misspoke but let's take a look at what
she said arizona is recognized for two
minutes
thank you representative jordan i rise
in opposition to h.r
2377. oh i have five grandchildren
i would do anything anything to protect
my five grandchildren including as a
last resort shooting them if i had to to
protect the lives of my grandchildren
have we really gone so woke
that a god-fearing flag-waving
republican can't shoot her own
grandchildren to save them what on earth
does this mean like if they're about to
shoot themselves dead
she would shoot them in the hand so they
drop the gun
and don't kill themselves like what what
does it even mean what possible scenario
would this even be an option
and the scenario i'm landing on is she
seems very unstable
and should probably have guns taken away
it sounds like she's very very dangerous
now what was her response to this lesko
responded by attacking so-called gun
control zealots
for suggesting she would shoot her own
grandchildren but that's exactly what
she said
instead of attacking the people saying
what the hell is she talking about as
zealots she could just say oh i misspoke
i did say i would shoot my grandchildren
but that's not what i meant
oh all right well that's simple newsweek
reports that debbie lescoe suggested her
critics are misrepresenting her comments
well i just played it for you
we we could listen to it one more time
it was very clearly recognized for two
minutes
thank you representative
jordan i rise in opposition to h.r
2377 okay i have five grandchildren i
have five grandchildren
i would do anything anything to protect
my five grandchildren she would do
anything to protect her grandchildren
including as a last resort shooting them
including as a last resort shooting them
now is there some other noun in the
sentence that she might be referring to
when she says them no the only noun she
has talked about
is her grandchildren so why can't she
just say i misspoke
i said in my in my zealous
defense of my own grandchildren i
misspoke what i meant was
i would even go so far as to shoot an
intruder
in order to save my grandchildren why
can't you just say that is it this is
the trumpian influence she says
something bonkers it might be as simple
as she misspoke
and her response is to attack so-called
gun control
zealots for going after her
um
yeah i guess this is part of the whole
trumpian thing where you can't apologize
anymore or you can't just say i i just
said the wrong thing i misspoke you
can't do it anymore so she just has to
attack people bizarre stuff i hope
somebody has checked but just to be safe
i hope someone has checked on her five
grandchildren
there are some republicans already
endorsing donald trump for 2024. donald
trump hasn't even announced he's running
in 2024 and one of the things pat and i
spoke about yesterday on the
award-winning bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad is that this 2024
presidential election may be the most
interesting and unique presidential
election i will have ever covered and
probably that i'll ever have been alive
for think about what we could be heading
towards uh that i have been alive for so
far i don't want to you know in the
future anything could happen
we could have
the incumbent president joe biden
not run for re-election
the sitting vice president kamala harris
trying for the nomination and losing it
potentially she's very unpopular right
now that's just a fact that's not my
opinion
kamala harris is perfectly fine person
she's just not very popular right now so
you could have biden say i'm not running
for reelection harris saying i am
running and democratic voters might
choose someone else so the sitting vp
might lose
the democratic nomination on the
republican side you could have a former
president one term president donald
trump who lost was removed from office
trying to become the nominee
that alone would be unique and he may
also lose it's not obvious that donald
trump would win he probably would win
based on current polling but ron
desantis is surging every two weeks
every week or two ron desantis is doing
better and better in 2024 betting
markets
that i can't think of another time when
that's happened
sitting president doesn't run vp tries
for the nomination up against a one-term
president also trying for the nomination
so trump not even running some
republicans already endorsing him here's
jim jordan a horrible person by any
stretch of the imagination saying what
we need is trump back in the white house
simple video so uh yeah but this will
not change until donald trump's back in
the white house and we get a
commander-in-chief who knows how to lead
but you're absolutely right hundreds of
pilots okay so jim jordan says we need
trump back in the white house
congresswoman lauren bobert or bo bear
she has put up a trump 2024 flag
at shooter's grill which i guess is her
restaurant in colorado or something so
she's already on trump 2024.
marco rubio has said if trump runs then
yeah i would support him here's an
interview
from a few months ago for marco rubio a
florida republican senator the senator
added that he's confident the state's
2022 election cycle is secure looking
ahead to 2024 i asked senator rubio if
he would support donald trump for
another term as president
yeah look if donald trump is going to
run for president in 2024 he'll be the
republican nominee and and of course i
would support him in that i mean we're
far long ways off from that a lot's
gonna happen between now and then true
so there's marco rubio who says he would
support trump if trump were the nominee
and then i mean this is just it's almost
a little weird even mitch mcconnell
the senate now minority leader former
majority leader republican who has said
so many negative things about trump
uh has clashed with trump when it comes
to
the january 6 riots trump has been
attacking mcconnell for so long
even mitch mcconnell says yeah i mean if
he's the nominee i would support him
well there's a lot to happen between now
and 24 i've got at least four members
that i think are planning on running for
president plus some for some governors
and others there's no incumbent should
be a wide open race and fun for you all
to cover
if the president was the party's nominee
would you support him uh the nominee of
the party absolutely
yeah so
for all the the negative things that
mitch mcconnell has said about trump and
how horrifying trump's actions were
around january 6 all of it
um oh yeah if he's the nominee of course
i'll support him i guess it sounds like
there's really no one that mitch
mcconnell wouldn't support over a
democrat if they were the party's
nominee and then republican senator from
south carolina tim scott says of course
this is from a few months ago of course
he would support donald trump if donald
trump runs again in 2024. now on the
other side of this the the other
interesting component to this
is that there's a growing list of
republicans
who are not going to be supporting
donald trump in 2024 and there's kind of
three buckets of republicans and this
may change as things go forward there's
the people already supporting trump 2024
even though he's not a candidate there's
those who are just waiting probably to
kind of put their finger to the wind and
see does it look like the party wants
trump again or is it looking like it's
going to be desantis or what what you
know they're kind of fair-weather trump
supporters and then you've got the
people who have said i am not supporting
donald trump ever again of course this
includes liz cheney and adam kinzinger
the two republicans who are on the
january 6th committee but a former trump
ally arkansas governor asa hutchinson
has said he's not going to be supporting
trump or at least he may run against
trump he may run for the 2024 republican
nomination mitt romney who has said i
believe if trump runs he will win the
nomination but he would have to do it
without mitt romney's support and there
are others as well so shaping up and i
know that this is very unlike me you
know in 2012
um
when people were saying well no in 2013
when people were asking me questions
about the 2016 presidential i said we've
got to get past the 2014 midterm first
in 2017 when there was so much
discussion about 2020 i said we've got
to deal with the 2018 midterm first
this is an unusual situation so much of
the midterms relates directly to 2024
particularly when republicans are trying
to use the 2022 midterms to take control
of more state election systems so that
then they can give 24 to their nominee
no matter who wins in uh the actual
voting and on and on and on so this is a
unique situation in that the 22 and 24
elections are inextricably linked and as
i mentioned at the top of the segment 24
is looking like it could be one of the
wildest and most unusual situations i've
ever covered or even lived through i
mean you think about 1992 okay yeah bill
clinton defeated one term george h.w
bush not the most common scenario but
nothing compared to sitting president
doesn't run vp tries maybe loses former
one-term president tries to run maybe
wins maybe loses that's wild and i
expect it to be absolutely insane we're
going to take a quick quick break we're
going to come back we're going to
examine
a radical republican's track record of
gaffes and try to ascertain
is she really
this dumb i mean i don't know any other
way to say it is she really this dumb
remember that saturday night donald
trump will be in alaska
trying to damage
lisa murkowski
republican senator lisa murkowski's
re-election campaign he doesn't like her
he calls her a rhino
we will be live with that on youtube
twitch and facebook i hope you'll join
me but let's take a quick break plenty
more still to come today
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right many of you have asked me
david do you think marjorie taylor green
the radical trumpist republican
congresswoman is she really this dumb
and ignorant when she says things like
her rights were fragrantly violated or
that there was a peach tree dish or that
nancy pelosi's gazpacho police did
something is she really this dumb or are
these incredibly brilliantly
orchestrated viral moments that are
contrived and planned to get her
attention
or are they sort of like verbal glitches
in the style of trump so let's see if we
can figure it out one by one
first of all there's a new one of these
marjorie taylor green recently said that
people were stroking fear of course the
term is stoking fear stroking fear and
paranoia in everyone saying uh terrible
messages ahead of time right they were
stroking fear so first and foremost
these are not
the types of glitches that trump has
when trump has these glitches
he either is having a problem reading or
he's having the brain glitch no more
drock
the drop boxes
exactly mexico sure a rhino named mitt
romney truth essential then he went
donald trump yeah donald trump like
trump knows his own name that's just a
verbal glitch obama yeah he knows it's
he knows it's barack obama so i would
put the marjorie taylor green
gaffs
squarely outside of the kind of like
brain glitch trump thing so then the
question becomes are these calculated or
are these just natural utterances so
again here's the latest one from
yesterday stroking fear stroking fear
and paranoia in everyone saying uh
terrible messages ahead of time now that
one could be that she misread it
i think maybe she doesn't know the word
stoking she seems to be reading on this
one
we've then got when her rights were
fragrantly violated
if you have never smelled marjorie
taylor green be fragrantly violated then
you don't know what's going on out there
and why their due process rights are
being so fragrantly and horrifically
violated so that one's not reading she's
not reading that
is that deliberate is it some kind of
brilliant joke which gets five million
views and more
it doesn't feel like it
it doesn't feel like it here's another
example this is her infamous gazpacho
police of course hoping to refer to the
gestapo not only do we have the dc jail
which is the dc gulag but now we have
nancy pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of congress spying on the
legislative work that we do
it doesn't seem contrived it seems like
she really has no idea what she's
talking about um here's the last one
where she referred to a petri dish
as a peach tree dish like what could
that even mean what does she think a
peach tree dish is you have to accept
the fact that the government totally
wants to provide surveillance on every
part of your life they want to know when
you're eating they want to know if
you're eating a cheeseburger which is
very bad because bill gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that grows in a
peachtree dish
i don't think that that's fake
i just i just don't think that that's
fake i think she's really that dumb and
it's nothing to make fun of i mean
education is a so
her being dumb
is a tragedy her being ignorant is a
tragedy of the american education system
people voting for her anyway despite
being so clueless
is that also because of the same
education system or should we be saying
the real the real crazies
are the people voting for her like in
most countries if someone like marjorie
taylor green ran for office or something
she would just be laughed off of the
ballot so maybe really the concern as
we've been saying with trump is the
people willing to vote for her
let me know what you think i mean as
i've said before
it's not particularly unusual
that people like donald trump exist or
that they might be narcissists and might
want power
that exists everywhere the difference is
the united states had 60 something
million people i don't remember the
numbers who in 2016 were willing to vote
for him to put him in power that seems
to be
the unique part of the united states
because you know trump could just be
some ceo in a german boardroom or
something like that i'm like okay these
people exist everywhere but they
wouldn't make them the prime minister uh
the jury the the chancellor of germany
i don't know so to me it seems that this
is this is really more a reflection of
the voters dumb people exist uh ignorant
people exist marjorie taylor green is
one of them it's
in part a result of the the failing
education system of the united states
but i don't think these are contrived
gaffes i don't think these are
calculated viral moments i think she's
just this dumb let me know if you
disagree hey this is sort of like an
exercise in humiliating futility
uh remember the truckers these these
right-wing truckers who were going to
protest mandates and demand liberty and
all these things
one of the leaders of the right-wing
truckers has been arrested
and he was arrested because he came to
the attention of police while protesting
non-existent covered mandates you might
be saying wait a second david the
truckers aren't still going are they
because there's no more there's no
mandates there's some industries have
requirement but like what what are we
even talking about when we say covet
mandates things are essentially back to
normal it would be really dumb to get
yourself arrested during a protest for
something that's not even worthy of
protest anymore that's exactly what this
guy did our friend zachary patrizo from
a daily beast wrote this article
right-wing trucker's leader gets
arrested while protesting non-existent
coveted mandates in dc here is a picture
of david santa riddell if you're looking
at the picture you might understand why
his nickname is santa the leader of the
right-wing and covet anti-vaxx 1776
restoration movement former formerly
called the people's convoy was arrested
near the national mall on wednesday
after his group came to town protesting
non-existent mandates far-right proud
boy member and leader david santa
riddell was taken into custody for a
warrant out of maryland
per dc metro police officers he was
placed under arrest for the arrest
warrant that he had issued for him if
there is a warrant out for your arrest
maybe it's not a good idea
to get even more people paying attention
to you and i guess riddell asked police
to brief cameras about what is happening
and they explained what's going on this
is like adding insult to injury you're
protesting something that doesn't even
exist and it turns out he was wanted and
now you get yourself arrested what did
he do
can i speak for a second sure i spoke
with that with uh david over here he
said it's okay for me to share this
information with you
obviously there's privacy but he's okay
with that he's being placed under arrest
he asked me to let you know because he
has a warrant for his arrest out of the
state of maryland for obstructing the
roadway that's right in the roadway the
metropolitan police was made aware of
this arrest warrant therefore we have to
take action and execute the war
by the way
this officer sounds almost apologetic
i don't know if you are getting the same
vibes as me but it's sort of
strange you're not even part of the
states
oh that is brilliant you're not even in
maryland and washington dc isn't even
part of the states so um
arrest warrants are interstate and then
extradition from one state to another is
sort of like the next step in a separate
thing but there's really nothing
super controversial outside of these
fringe movements about the fact that
warrants are valid across state lines
you guys are a bunch of groups for the
constitutional breaking power
there's nothing unconstitutional about
um acting on a warrant from a different
state
completely uncontroversial
we're here till he's gone
okay so just just so you understand how
this works since the warrants inside the
state of maryland
okay it's not too far that's five
minutes down the road
it seems like the officer being called a
coward for following the law is
explaining that yes the the warrant is
from maryland but he would now be
extradited and remember
this this guy is only here because he's
the the arrestee because he was
protesting covet mandates which don't
exist
you are
coward
first amendment is protected
for whatever violations occurred in the
state of maryland on apparently july 4th
or 5th a warrant was issued by a judge
in maryland for this individual's arrest
therefore we were notified this warrant
is extraditable he is here we are aware
of it
yeah so that means
we place them under arrest he'll go in
front of a judge here imagine after
having to explain such simple things to
these people such simple uncontroversial
things
he'll be extradited back to the state of
maryland to face those charges okay so
he will not be staying here in dc
eventually he will go back to maryland
in front of the judge eventually you say
eventually
so he will be processed here today in
the city he will go see a judge here
depending on how the process works if he
wishes to wave or not waive extradition
then he will go to maryland and see a
judge in maryland no problem okay that's
how the process works
man what what a nightmare i don't even
know at this point what these groups are
trying to achieve because the mandates
are gone yeah they're defeat the
mandates what mandates are you talking
about um is it a grift for donations and
if so who's even giving to these obvious
scams uh i truly don't get it but really
a self-inflicted self-inflicted
humiliation arrested
while protesting mandates that do not
exist we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192 david p
really important topic
in today's voicemail
these nebulous
nine-month abortions
okay the right
is in a frenzy
over supposed nine-month abortions
listen to the voicemail then we'll
discuss
hi david i just had a quick question
i keep hearing
from stephen crowder and
lauren vover and other people that
there's a nine month you can have a nine
month
abortion in there in colorado
i was just wondering if that is an
anecdote or if it's just hyperbole or if
it's rhetoric
uh your thoughts on this would be much
appreciated okay
um something like 91 of abortions happen
extremely early i forget the exact
number of weeks but
very very early 91
and then the other nine percent
uh almost all of those happen
um in an intermediate period of the
pregnancy
typically now we're talking about for
medical reasons
now what the right has seized upon
is that there are some states
that don't put a limit
of gestational age
legally on when an abortion could be
done so what the starting point for this
claim that oh you can you can be
39 weeks pregnant
walk in and say i'd like an abortion and
everybody's gonna say sure sure okay
what it stems from is that there are
certain states that don't put a number
of weak limit on abortions legally
speaking now
obstetricians have weighed in on this
endlessly and they have all said
recently under oath in congressional
testimony this does not happen when you
have an abortion at the extraordinarily
late stage of an abortion of a pregnancy
that is being discussed
it is
essentially
aside from being so so rare
it's because a genetic abnormality is
found in the fetus
uh that that makes evident that this is
not going to be able to be
a person that survives either at all or
for more than some
minuscule amount of time outside of the
womb horrible horrible situations
genetic abnormalities and other things
uh an extraordinarily difficult decision
is made
um at that point to to essentially
accelerate by what might be
days or a couple of weeks would it what
is inevitably going to be a non-viable
pregnancy horrible situation extremely
rare other situation is it is determined
that there is a um a situation that
endangers the life of the mother
okay
these are
insanely rare situations that do
sometimes happen
that are very difficult for the pregnant
women and their families
and
are not
what the right loves to dream up which
is
a woman decides on week 39
five days before the 40-week mark or the
due date you know what i just don't want
the baby could we do an abortion and obs
have already testified it never happens
but if someone did come in and they are
essentially full term
and said i don't want the baby let's do
an abortion obs have said we wouldn't do
it we would say well this is a full-term
baby like we could we can do if there's
a problem with a pregnancy we could do a
c-section and then
we could look at adoption if you're not
you know we're
this is an imaginary situation that the
right has dreamed up that almost does
not happen so the origins of it are
there are states that don't enshrine by
statute a limit on the number of weeks
for abortions
that doesn't mean women are walking in
two days before their due date and
saying i'd like an abortion for no
medically relevant reason i just don't
want the baby doesn't happen obs have
explained it it's a red herring it's not
even really relevant to the abortion
debate which again
these right-wingers who say oh people
are walking in at nine months
they're often also opposed to abortions
at five weeks
so don't even be tricked into thinking
that this is really even the issue for
them we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today speaking of abortion
how are women now in certain states that
are
have or will be banning abortion
altogether
how are they going to obtain
abortion pills
that are or will be banned there's
already an entire infrastructure being
put in place to try to support women
in those situations and in those states
second
democrats are increasingly saying to joe
biden
you do have some authority to take major
steps towards cannabis legalization you
can't just say recreationally legal
everywhere but there are steps joe biden
can take what about doing that we will
talk about it and number three
drag queens are now the new target of
intimidation by the far right as i
tweeted this morning there are lots of
right wingers who seem to think drag
queens and trans people are
interchangeable terms
they are not
and it might not come as a shock to many
of you that right wingers are confused
about some things and we will talk about
that on the bonus show as well sign up
at
joinpakman.com you can get instant
access by signing up on our website you
can also get a discount off of the price
of membership by using the coupon code
big voting 22. i look forward to
welcoming you into the ranks of
membership i also will be streaming live
saturday night the trump rally in alaska
this will be a doozy i hope you'll join
me on youtube twitch and or facebook
and otherwise we'll be back with a new
show tomorrow
you